hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut er sogar
kurz luft holen
ich habe heute etwas vor was eigentlich
anders geplant war aber ich jetzt mal
ganz kurz akkuwechsel ist mal wieder auf
mich zugekommen und hat mich gefragt
alex hast du nicht wieder bock unseren
neuen saugroboter zu testen und ich
hatte schon so vieles auf roboter ich
habe ja auch letztens schon mal mit
denen zusammengearbeitet eigentlich den
mit zwei minuten in irgendeinem video
erwähnen ich habe mich allerdings
bisschen damit auseinandergesetzt und
dachte mir da sind so coole neue sachen
ball
da kann man auch mal ein video zu machen
so und wir testen heute mal an die leute
die sich jetzt nicht so für saugen
roboter interessieren ist ja auch völlig
in ordnung bleibt er kurz dran
vielleicht werdet ihr dann auch bisher
gericht dass das hier ist auf jeden fall
das paket ganz schön groß größer als das
letzte und das öffnen wir jetzt mal
hier haben wir das dringend ich hatte
vorher auch schon den osmo t8 a wie das
war den vorgängen haben wir jetzt den
osmo t8 plus und ihr seht schon dass sie
ein bisschen anders aus wir haben hier
nämlich eine automatische
update-funktion das heißt ihr müsst
euren saugroboter nicht mal selber
lehrern irgendwann das macht er alles
selber dann gibt es auch noch das neue
to detect 3d system das heißt der fährt
nicht irgendwo gegen wollen nicht gegen
fahren soll wenn irgendwas im raum liegt
dann fährt er schön aus
wir werden das alles mal ein bisschen
testen ich interessiere mich auf jeden
fall sehr für die dinger einfach weil
sie zu meinem alltag mittlerweile dazu
gehören deswegen bin ich auch immer sehr
gespannt was da so neues gibt und ja
irgendwann einmal den saugroboter hier
sind irgendwelche extra zusätze drin
haben und so und dann haben wir hier
noch die ladestation die diesmal halt
ein bisschen anders aussieht
also ich hab so was vorher noch nie
gesehen ok muss ich hier noch irgend
etwas bestimmtes erklären ich weiß nicht
ich kenne mich ja selber noch nicht so
mit ausgepackt mir jetzt mal aus und
schließen dann an
oder dann wenn ich mal gespannt wir
haben sogar diesmal ein weißes modell
der letzte war schwarz erst mal die
ganze bude hier befreien sagt mein ding
sieht das erst mal so aus wie der
vorgänger hier mal vorne wieder eine
kamera drin wie beim letzten auch das
war ja so lustig du hast ja theoretisch
auch eine überwachungskamera drin wenn
irgendwer bei dir zu hause einbricht
kannst du darüber sehen oder das kann
halt aufgezeichnet werden theoretisch
halt ich habe das jetzt noch nie benutzt
aber es geht gut viel zu erklären muss
ich hoffentlich nicht die meisten von
euch die das jetzt bis hierhin schauen
wissen ja sicherlich wie so etwas
funktioniert nur dass hier das habe ich
heute wie gesagt vorher noch nie gesehen
und das testen wir jetzt mal dass sie
war übrigens das vorgängermodell ansicht
die seen relativ gleich aus also viele
unterschiede gibt es da jetzt nicht so
ein paar kleinigkeiten natürlich aber
ich nehme immer das neueste deswegen
wird er jetzt zur seite gepackt
beziehungsweise den schenke ich wieder
meinen eltern oder meiner oma meine oma
hat auch schon so einen die hat sich
richtig gefreut und bei mir steht dann
jetzt zukünftig der hier natürlich an
der gleichen stelle wie der ja auch
schon
also im wohnzimmer nach vorne also danke
für alles du hast du auf jeden fall sehr
geholfen aber man muss platz machen für
neues ist ja wie im fußball
da kommen auch immer neue youngstars
dazu die vielleicht dann plötzlich
besser sind
noront ich brauche das mal kurz auf wir
sehen uns gleich wieder so leute ich hab
das ganze jetzt hier mal aufgebaut
hinter mir auf dem boden der letzte
stand ging auf jeden fall ziemlich
schnell das hier ist jetzt diese box die
war vorher halt nur nicht dabei wo auch
schon so einen beutel drin ist und da
wird dann der ganze staat der ganze
recht einfach so rein gezogen das essen
jetzt mal wie das war eben alles ein und
dann geht's los
ihr müsst euch nur halt vor hier die eco
weg sap runterladen könnt ihr dann
einfach jeden roboter hier unten roboter
hinzufügen wir sondern die ganze modelle
das habe ich schon alles gemacht hier
ist er jetzt dem osmo t8 plus da klicken
wir mal drei okay und jetzt kann man
hier eine karte erstellen ich wusste ja
kurz hinlegen als grobe umrisse von
eurer wohnung und das lasse ich den
jetzt einfach mal eben machen
okay leute ich habe jetzt hier eine
halbe stunde gewartet der hat jetzt 35
quadratmeter abgescannt ich habe extra
erst mal nur das wohnzimmer den flur und
mein badezimmer gemacht das hat er jetzt
hier in vier räume getrennt a b c und d
aus dem büro in zwei räume also bären 10
man kann zum beispiel auch eine gezielte
reihe von dem man sagt man macht man
global zimmer und deswegen ist halt die
karte ganz gut das ist aber langweilig
und selbst erklärt deswegen zeigt das
jetzt gar nicht ich will nur die neuen
funktionen mal eben testen ich habe hier
gerade schon mal so ein paar sachen hier
hingelegt hier war eine mütze da waren
schuhe es ist zum beispiel einmal
passiert dass ein tauchroboter hier die
lampe inter situation hat es die
gefallen weil das halt nicht gecheckt
hat und der hat jetzt so sensor um das
zu umgehen ich habe jetzt hier einfach
mal die schuhe hin gepackt und das gute
ist ich habe hier noch dreck vom alten
roboter einfach auf den boden damit er
etwas wasser aufnehmen kann
[Musik]
das haben wir sind viel das ist recht so
heftig wie viel zeug damit dass man im
eigenen von zwei jungen dann wollen wir
mal okay let's go hier kann man jetzt
ganz gut sehen wie der saugroboter
einfach um die lampe herum fährt und
nicht gegen diese stellten prallt und
die dann halt mitnimmt so dass sie
umfeld sondern das schön erkennen und
einfach drum rum gleitet also das echt
sehr nice mache jetzt keine faxen jetzt
gucken wir eine menge leute zu
[Applaus]
und hier kann man jetzt sehen dass er
sich um den showroom tastet und ihnen
sozusagen gar nicht berührt und der
nächste dreck bitte alles schön
mitnehmen das sieht nämlich ekelhaft der
ist jetzt fertig hat alles schön sauber
gemacht und jetzt nicht das seil gezogen
ein bisschen was es auf jeden fall schon
drin
das war und wie man sehen kann alles
komplett leer also die dinger nehmen
einen immer mehr und mehr arbeit ab
immer gespannt was in fünf jahren ist ob
dann überhaupt noch irgendwas machen
muss oder ob die wohnung einfach ja ich
weiss nicht irgendwas neues für uns ist
kommt er immer hinzu ich verlinke euch
den song butter um in der teamcheck das
gerne ab danke auch noch mal ein eco
wächst freut mich immer sehr und wir
sehen uns dann hier morgen um 19 uhr
gibt's neues video das war zu mir hat
ein